on vient tout juste de recevoir les
premières images de ce drame qui vient
de se dérouler à 17h25 banques à
l'université de montréal la
polytechnique tireur fou a fait feu à
l'intérieur de l'édifice
vous venez de voir un extrait du
documentaire polytechnique ce qu'il
reste du 6 décembre d'ailleurs r10 vous
présentera ce documentaire dans quelques
minutes tout juste après notre émission
de 24,60 mes invités n'étaient pas
encore nés ou encore trop jeune pour
comprendre l'ampleur de la tragédie qui
est survenu à ce moment là dans ces
lieux qui allait devenir plus tard pour
eux leur école parce qu'ils ont choisi
de faire des études en génie je vous les
présente
camille proulx bachelière en génie
chimique maintenant étudiante à la
maîtrise en économie circulaire stéphane
dauphin pierre il était très jeune au
moment du drame et il vient de terminer
son doctorat en génie industriel viviano
aubin bachelier en génie mécanique
maintenant étudiante à la maîtrise en
génie énergétique à vous trois bonnes
bonne soirée merci d'être avec nous
merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation
on vous a donné un devoir à faire ces
derniers jours c'était de regarder le
documentaire alors qu'amiens et viviane
vous étiez pas nés au moment de la
tragédie
stéphane vous aviez 6 ans sauf erreur
regardons un extrait de ce documentaire
qui vraiment est très poignant aux
knicks
quand marc lépine aux illégaux d'un côté
les filles de l'autre je me suis
réfugiée en arrière ni colonnes on s'est
dirigé dans un coin donc là si la porte
est là les feuilles sont vraiment à
l'opposé de la porte dans un coin et
moi j'ai pas encore tout à fait pas
parce que je suis encore rempli de tous
ces mythes qui disent que l'on protège
les femmes en les femmes et les enfants
d'abord puis et donc il est très
probable qu'ils aient un guet-apens pour
l'ego dans ma tête et audi qui étaient
là qui étaient là parce qu'on était des
filles puis qu'il voulait tuer les
filles pjj répondu ben non on n'est pas
des féministes moi ça a toujours été
clair
ma soeur est décédée par ce qui était
une femme de will go qui avait dit
probablement des gros problèmes
psychologiques peu importe mais sans son
acte d'état dirigé clairement vers les
femmes le juste de les punir
pas eu l'effet inverse ce qu'il a
accompli en fait il nous a réveillés à
faire plus j'ose espérer que toutes les
guettait la fonction puis le fait que
j'ai quatre filles
quelle coïncidence samassa mollet allumé
encore plus sur le sujet et maintenant
j'en fais un sujet de discussion assez
fréquent que méfaits des foires où les
yeux une voiture sans doute mais c'est
pour moi c'est important
oui il fait bien d'en parler c'est
important de paris camille vous avez
donc bull documentaire comment vous avez
réagi
moi ça me stresse ans et buzz
en fait en cinq ans d'études appels
techniques l'ayant pas vu qu on est
conscient du fait que des femmes qui
sont décédées et tout mais on n'est pas
appelée à être vraiment mais le
franchement avec le documentaire je me
suis vraiment plonger à l'intérieur un
peu de les émotions qui a été véhiculé
viviane c'est vous qui dites le 6
décembre on commémore ce à 15 secondes
de dans l'année puis mais après ça pour
vous êtes dans votre recherche de fin
d'année pour la commémoration
vous y pensez pas vraiment ce qu'est ce
que ça a eu comme effet pour vous le duc
manh on sait ce qui est arrivé on va le
commémorer mais ça va pas attrister
complètement l'ambiance a poli la vie
continue mais c'est sûr que de voir
vraiment
les images archives d'entendre les
témoignages on comprend vraiment ce qui
s'est pas fait on le vit presque ces
faits extrêmement émouvante a beaucoup
touchés comme documentaire ce que vous
aviez six ans mais vous aviez un lien
avec polytechnique à ce moment là c'est
que votre père étudiait n'est ce pas
polytechnique
comment vous avez vécu où vous regardez
ce document en fait c'est toujours un
peu ça me rappelle beaucoup de souvenirs
j'ai reconnu des images que j'avais vu
qu'ils convoyaient fréquemment la télé
et c'est ça donc lorsque j'ai vu le
moment fait ce que je voyais c'est
j'imaginais mon père qui était là où des
amis m'ont parlé beaucoup d'amis de mon
père qui était là également
donc j'ai un peu inquiet pour eux avec
mon regard de 6 ans donc on comprend pas
trop fallait rassurer un peu par rapport
à ça donc c'est un peu le souvenir que
j'ai beaucoup le dessin
donc je comprends que comme étudiant
britannique vous savez ce qui s'est
passé un espoir peut-être pas l'ampleur
de ce que ça a eu à ce moment là vous
avez regardé le documentaire vous êtes
retourné à polytechnique depuis que vous
avez regardé le documentaire est ce que
vous voyez votre école différemment
camille mois lundi c'était la dernière
journée de course officiel je me
promenais à l'intérieur parce que j'ai
vu c'est le samedi matin puis
honnêtement si j'avais j'ai eu le goût
craignent un moment donné ça allait
jusqu'à même rentrer dans l'école
rentrant l'école en reconnaissant en
imaginant tu sais on prend tellement
pour acquis la sécurité à quel point sur
un banc d'école était dans un endroit un
environnement favorable pour étudier
dans un endroit calme on pense pas qu'il
va avoir quelqu'un qui vont vouloir te
tue été imaginé en 1989
on pensait encore moins parce que sans
dire qu'on est habitués à ce genre
d'événement là il y en a eu beaucoup
plus depuis 1989 en tout cas pour le
pays pour le canada ce test est une
première cependant quand vous retournez
à polytechnique après avoir vu le
documentaire vous vous sentez comment
j'ai toujours la même fut une genre de
frustration par rapport à ce qui est
arrivé de se dire il y à des femmes qui
ont été agressés en fin de compte parce
que en étudier et leur seul crime c'est
est de vouloir devenir ingénieur qui se
trouvait sur un peu injuste parce que je
dis moi j'ai le droit de faire de ce
danger ni mai
elles l ont pas droit c'est un peu le
sentiment qu'on a en revenant qu'en
regardant le documentaire vient de vous
quand vous remettez les quais à
polytechnique après avoir regardé le
documentaire vous sentez comment c'est
beaucoup d'émotion surtout le fait
qu'ils nomment les locaux le numéro
exact
après nous tenons peut aller voir ses
locaux en fait je pense que j'aurais
préféré ne pas connaître les numéros de
la coupe donc j'ai fait tout mon
parcours ou presque la police sans les
connaître et je pense que c'était
peut-être mieux parce que on peut dit
pour moi c'est vraiment un lieu d'étude
n'était pas un lieu de drame donc ça
vous aurait envahi d'une certaine façon
ce drame pendant vos études
ah oui préféré ne pas avoir su toute
l'ampleur de la chose ou et puis en fait
depuis que en fait l'année passée me
paraît un peu accident j'avais connu 1 1
et numéro des locaux puis depuis à
chaque fois que je passe devant
chauprade de penser à autre chose au
oui/non tout à fait même si c'est ça ça
fait 30 ans mais parce que dans les cols
les plus de traces ou non il ya encore
les tables et les chaises sont les mêmes
mais y'a pas d'autre que ce qu'on veut
on valorise et de compromettre les comme
la claque d'une plaque commémorative
un mec qui est dans un endroit où faut
savoir qu'elle est là pour l'apprécier
ou voir justement la place dès
maintenant mais ce n'est pas beaucoup de
travail est à l'extérieur c'est très
sobre et poli ça reste vraiment un lieu
d'enseignement et à travers le
documentaire juste souligner à travers
le documentaire on ne peut être une
bribe où un semblant d émotion que les
gens ont vécu à ce moment là mais on n'a
aucune idée en réalité de la force la
sagesse qui est les gens par exemple
nathalie provost qui fait souvent des
témoignages cette famille est
exceptionnel puis elle était blessée
s'est fait tirer dessus par le tireur ce
moment là il a survécu
elle raconte son histoire de façon très
émotive et émouvante aussi les étudiants
partiez l'entrejeu d'épargné est ce que
on relate ces événements là est ce qu'on
est ce qu on y pense qu'on y réfléchisse
quand on a des qualités il ya toujours
une période autour justement
enfin début décembre ou est ce que oui
on en parle un tout petit peu entre nous
on a des petits échanges un peu pour se
rappeler mais c'est pas des très grandes
conventions aussi quelqu'un par exemple
des nouveaux étudiants
ah qu'est ce qui se passe de céder sa
place dès le moment où il ya toujours
quelqu'un peut expliquer un peu
l'événement puis bon et il y en a il ya
me dis que j'ai beaucoup d'étudiants qui
ont qui vivait pas au québec afin qu'ils
disaient étrangers
exactement c'est que j'inventais qui est
donc qui sont pas au courant des
serments de ce qui se passe mais qui
sont sensibilisés au tour du 6 décembre
ce qui s'est passé vous étiez au courant
de ce qui s'était passé
viviane le 6 décembre mais dans votre
dans votre choix de carrière ou dans
votre choix de la politique ne sert pas
jouer où ça a joué
en fait moi je suis moi j'allais en
sciences parce que jamais les sciences
puis que je voyais pas d'obstacle à ça
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya comme un
sentiment de victoire de dire il y aura
pas gagné on ignorait pas fait peur aux
filles les filles continuent d'aller en
génie puis mai mais le tout fut applaudi
par ses 2 7% 89 à 28 pour ça on l'a mais
si c'est quand même encore 28% seulement
il ya encore du travail à faire mais
clairement il ya une progression en huit
lancers alors justement on va parler de
poly 2019 des conditions dans lesquelles
les femmes aussi peuvent travailler dans
le secteur génie
et encore des parts faire semble-t-il
vous avez des anecdotes à nous raconter
là dessus on poursuit donc la discussion
dans quelques minutes
polytech'nice une tragédie qui a marqué
le québec agenais c'est surtout le
visage de 14 femmes tuées parce qu'elles
étaient des femmes
[Musique]
où
oh
bon
[Musique]
trente ans plus tard quel impact le
drame de polytechnique at il eu sur
notre société je poursuis la discussion
avec trois étudiants en génie de
polytechnique à montréal cam et ypres où
stéphane dauphin pierre et viviane aubin
elles ont été tués parce qu'ils étaient
des femmes
le tueur en avaient contre les femmes
contre les féministes disait-il
est-ce que vous vous sentez que les
femmes ont leur place dans le secteur du
génie ou est ce que vous sentez qu'elle
doive encore se battre pour faire leur
place quand même oui aux deux réponses
elles ont leur place dans le domaine du
génie oui et oui elles doivent encore se
battre je peut-être apporter une petite
anecdote will passé l'an dernier
en réalité il y avait deux candidats
pour le même maintenant on fait deux
postes de disponibles deux candidats qui
avaient exactement le même
le même profil même étude bref
autrement dit quand est venu le temps de
négocier les contrats le globe a eu dix
mille de plus par rapport à la fin pour
le même travail pour le même travail
avec moi-même compétences exacte et vous
expliquer sur comment plusieurs facteurs
peut-être le fait qu' on veut dire la
négociation était mieux fait d'un côté
ou de l'autre mais reste que en tant que
décideur
si on accepte à cause d'une négociation
donné dix mille de plus ben l'autre le
profil elle-même
donc ça devrait être équitable en
principe cela devrait être équitable
mais dans les faits ce n'est pas
nécessairement d'accord c'était pas nous
vous le voyez comment c'est les femmes
dans le domaine du génie il ya un combat
qui a été mené l on dit toujours tout à
l'heure que c'est le cadet des étudiants
polytechnique sont les camps 28% on se
trouve ils ont de la difficulté à faire
leur place ou moins impressionnant j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut demander aux
femmes pour le savoir mais nous moi
personnellement je trouve qu'on essaie
d'être plus appliqués ont passé on dit
même c'est des gens comme tout le monde
donc on fait juste les accueillir des
ingénieurs l'ingénieur examen le gars
était un ingénieur qui j'en ai eu plus
j'étais dans plusieurs comités ou y
avait des femmes extraordinaires qui
travaille pas bien puis je suis en fait
pas vraiment la différence entre les
deux exactement pour viviez vous levez
vous vivez vous une certaine
discrimination pression au quotidien et
justement on est traité un peu comme
comme ligue 1
on fait partie de la gamme mais c'est
sûr que des fois dans certains projets
plus technique
je pense que il ya encore du travail à
faire pour que les avis techniques des
femmes soit autant considérer que ceux
des hommes on va avoir tendance à plus
chercher à valider ce que nous fait ce
qu'il ne fait inédit sur le point de vue
technique que ce qui se distingue donc
un préjugé favorable à l'avis technique
d'un garçon et que je lui est
défavorable à l'avis technique d'une
fuite mais des fois c'est 6 tellement
bien conscient des folies gens et les
jeunes en sont même pas conscients
acte met donc ça fait partie de la
culture où je pense que c'est pas
quelque chose qui provoquera peut dit je
pense c'est quelque chose qui est vrai
pour l'ensemble de la société
on nous apprend encore que un ingénieur
typiquement c'est un homme parce que
historiquement c'est l'été je pense que
tranquillement mais en ayant de plus en
plus de modèles femmes ingénieurs dont
on veut que déconstruire ces préjugés de
mais c'est sûr qu'il reste du travail à
faire et c'est les portes à des
programmes aussi parce que des
programmes moyens beaucoup plus de
familles après cet appareil est la
parité ou les voit même plus je pense
par exemple génie chimique
quand je suis rentrée c'était 50 % à -50
% femmes maintenant si 66% femmes pour
30%
bon mais voilà il peut il peut y avoir
des domaines où c'est à s'inverser bien
vous sentez-vous fait est ce que vous
vous sentez que vous avez porté une
cause dans le reportage dans le
documentaire on voit que le tueur s'en
est pris à ces femmes là parce qu'elle
était féministe il était contre le fait
qu' elle revendra ait pu se revendiquer
des choses
sentez vous que vous devez robot indiqué
nathalie provost disait on n'est pas
féministe on retourne à l'époque
en fait il n'y avait pas besoin du
féministes pour pratiquer ou en tout cas
voir leur plein de personnalités la
drève aller chercher leur succès donc
c'est un peu dans ce sens lui qu'il faut
comprendre l'antiféminisme mais
aujourd'hui moi je suis totalement
féministe le
la définition comme tel c'est avoir
l'égalité hommes femmes
donc voilà une équité pour l'équité et
l'égalité en même temps le fait que
viviane qu'on est qualifié cet attentat
lors d'attentats contre les femmes
d'attentats anti féministe est ce que
vous arrive trente ans plus tard quand
même parce que c'est un pas vous
conseiller ce que en effet c'est une
reconnaissance de ce qui a été de ce
drame là une autre reconnaissance de se
tramer oui moi je pensais vraiment
important d'un ami les choses telles
qu'elles sont c'était il ya une pudeur à
le nommer de telle qu'elle était là oui
j'ai de la douleur encore à comprendre
exactement d'où elle vient
mais c'est en même temps quelque chose
qu'on voit par rapport à plusieurs
enjeux qui sont reliés aux femmes et
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant le
documentaire et se termine en faisant
une référence au mouvement moi aussi et
là aussi il y avait une pudeur par
rapport aux non mais c'est pas vraiment
un crime ne fait pas vraiment un viol
donc hélas il ya on sent qu'un mouvement
on veut nommer les choses telles
qu'elles sont vu nommer les problèmes
auxquels les femmes font face puis je
pense est un peu dans la bonne direction
stéphane vous êtes le père d'une petite
fille de 2 ans 3 mai d'accord mais des
informations étaient fausses et des
presses kba est-ce que vous avez vu en
parler et si oui qu'est-ce que vous
allez lui dit je pense que je lui en
parler c'est sûr mais j'essaie vraiment
éduqué dans l'esprit on pourrait dire
une féministe que tu es capable de faire
tout ce que tu peux j'essaie de les
initier aux sciences l'initier à tout ce
qu' il n'y a pas de différence entre que
tu passes du sport tu es une femme
qu'est ce que tu veux un peu ça donne
force dans la ville force dans la vie
exact donc je pense que ça va rester
dans mon éducation pis peut-être que oui
éventuellement falloir que j'en parle vu
que mon père film on a fait petit frère
que je lui en parle éventuellement
souhaiteriez-vous qu'elle aille et
politiquement assez bizarre j'ai repensé
ensuite la question oui surtout en
regardant les filles qu'on avait fait à
polytechnique puis parce que tout le
monde a été celle en général c'est un
peu culturel pour nous oui j'aimerais
qu'elle y aille puis justement qu'elle
passe au pied n'est un peu à ce geste
mon ordi été fait
belle façon de voir les choses merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir participé à
l'émission ce soir d'avoir regarder ce
documentaire pour nous